(laughs)
- Hey guys.
Just been editing
here for a little while.
Gary and I were talking and
we figured we'd try
something different.
Yeah, so, here we go.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Charisma" by Shooting School)
- [Jordan] How's it feel?
- [Gary] Bad.
Knots in shoulders.
- [Jordan] So see this
thing in the back right here,
this is going right in to the
back of his scap, his stabilizers.
- [Gary] They don't want this
shit, Jordan. (Jordan laughs)
They want this,
go fucking hustle.
Make something happen.
Three hours of sleep,
gonna go work out,
well actually not
today seven hours.
Got some sleep in Seattle but
I got some sleep in Seattle.
I think that's supposed
to go the other way.
So early morning
here in Seattle.
About to go pitch this kid,
we're in the final two.
That's exciting.
Selling baseball cards
and athletes on cardboard and
now trying to sell
them to work with me
and then do baseball card
and football card deals
so really amazing.
You never know where
life's gonna take you.
Super proud of AJ
and Brian and Mook
at VaynerSports. We're
having an incredible first year.
Obviously, you guys have seen
the Jaylen Reeves Maybin,
Alvin Kamara, Jon Toth signings.
These are second round
pick type caliber guys
so it's a big first year
coming out the gate.
Exciting to
document this journey
when in three or four
years we'll be looking back
as one of the top
sports agents in the world.
Look at these early days.
I wish we had this
film on VaynerMedia
when it was six of us in a
conference room
starting the company.
That would be a real blast so
gonna go in there,
show him the value.
Like every business in my life,
how do we
disproportionately bring value
to the other side
of the table. Right?
And so, in the wine world it was
better wine than people
were buying
elsewhere at better prices.
And now today it's
showing these kids that
we can help them on the
field, off the field and
being a man after football.
And so excited about it,
we'll see what happens.
Travel life.
Just sitting here, landed,
reading the comments of episode
121 and 120 of DailyVee.
Just realizing that I always
talk about comments
being my oxygen
and as much as I love the love
and the admiration and the dabs
which are incredible
and thank you so much, guys,
it's incredible how much I get
value out of the insight.
If you go read the
comments on episode 2,--
- Right.
- [Gary] there were people that
basically said things like
I've been watching
you for three years,
hearing you for three years,
I didn't get how
hard you actually work.
- One more time.
- This,--
- Yeah.
- is gonna allow me to give away
an enormous amount
of free advice.
- Right.
- Whereas I could not do this--
- [Erik] Yeah.
- charge every, do
you know how many people
if tomorrow I announced I am no
longer putting out content.
- [Erik] Right.
- I am creating the
Gary Vaynerchuk school of
mastermind of marketing.
And it is $5,000 a month to
get what you've been getting.
Do you know how
much money I would make?
Tens of millions of dollars.
And, you know, you
always have those people that
want to give feedback,
critical feedback
just for doing it as an outlier,
it's not what I'm talking about
'cause I taste that energy.
I promise. I'm talking about the
people that are just really
giving insights to what
they're being effected by,
what they're seeing,
what editing they like,
which scenes they enjoy,
what they're
learning from the most.
It's all about this.
I'm so known for this.
But it's all about
(clicks tongue) this.
This mother fuckin' thing. This.
Because
the work I put
into consuming you guys,
not other videos or other
people but you, the end user,
that's the secret that
people haven't unlocked yet.
'Cause I don't consume
anybody else's stuff.
The reason I don't
consume historical things,
the reason I don't
consume anything else but you
is 'cause all of it matters.
("Charisma" by Shooting School)
- I think the really cool thing
about creating content
for DailyVee was that...
Thank you. You too.
- [Man] Thank you.
You guys can
influence on the content.
We read your comments.
American, here we are.
We want your feedback.
We love your feedback.
So yeah. Really appreciate it.
So weird. I'm in an
airport with a lot of people.
Just finishing up
DailyVee now on the plane.
I really commend Gary for
being in front of
the camera all the time.
- You're gonna be
editing in the room?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Okay. I'll see you later.
("Charisma" by Shooting School)